welcome back to harry potter quidditch
world cup guys we are getting very close
i can feel it to winning the world cup
right now we've got a really nice
advantage we're ahead by quite a bit in
points today you're gonna check out
three more matches really hope you guys
enjoyed the video today if you do make
sure to give it a thumbs up before you
go that's going to help more people find
the video enjoy
people of the internet retrorecontour
here i'm just a dad who loves games and
the stories they tell welcome back
to harry potter quidditch world cup
where today we are trying to win you can
now attend this year's
world cup excuse me madam hooch
trying to do an intro here
oh dude look at the pumpkins
all right
as cool as it is i've seen enough of the
intros now
i've seen enough of the intro oh dude
there dude no
[Applause]
oh my goodness wasting absolutely
no time
[Applause]
there we go
getting that combo game going early guys
germany wasting no time whatsoever
and just honestly like making things
very difficult here to start let's hit a
bludger their way
see if i can block him from scoring no
but the keeper is able to deflect
dude i mean they are just like
okay there we go
like man it is hard to even get a steal
on these guys
oh see nobody home
i really wish the game wouldn't do that
like
like i see somebody there but if i'm not
holding the analog stick just right
then
it just is like okay we're just gonna
throw it in midair to nobody
like no throw it there we go there we go
green
oh see they just like if you hold it too
long then they're gonna steal it so it
really does encourage passing
[Music]
but then if there's nobody home
it's just like
there we go all right 20 to 10.
not a bad start but man they are just
like i can really feel the pressure they
are they are putting on
[Applause]
but nobody's there what are you doing
it's one of the easiest things to do
go ahead and get the easy steal with the
little uh defensive special move right
there
no no no just score
there we go
[Applause]
man the combo system is just like
it's just not quite clear i like the
idea of it
who are you throwing to
oh we didn't even need to do that okay
you see i always like throwing the
faster passes
but if you're holding down the button
and then by the time you have to hold it
down for like a couple seconds or it
won't throw a fast pass
but if you're holding it down so when i
start pressing the button it's like oh
there's somebody right there
but then by the time i'm ready to let go
it's like oh they've moved
and they're not in view at all anymore
oh no way
there we go
all right we've settled down since that
rocky start here
uh but hope you guys are doing well this
week
put out a a couple of hogwarts legacy
videos lately
it's been kind of uh disappointing on
that front ever since the
lack of hogwarts legacy at the
playstation showcase
but still holding out hope i'm still
holding out hope before the end of the
year that that we'll get something
by the way guys we are just
ridiculously close to 10 000 subs
by the time you watch this actually we
may already have surpassed it uh
regardless of if we've hit it yet or
even if we haven't i just want to thank
you guys so much for all the support all
the encouraging words
in the comments
it really does keep me going it means a
lot
so
especially on these let's play videos
like i know
the let's play videos
they're for the die hard fans
they're they're for the guys and gals
who really you know
just support almost all the content that
i do
uh because obviously they don't get
nearly as many views but the reason i
keep making them
is because of your comments man because
of your feedback of how much you enjoy
these and i mean i'll be honest i enjoy
playing the games too but you know
the comments mean a lot is what i'm
trying to say
so keep those coming guys it like i said
it really does mean a lot uh nice off
the special move right there and we have
quickly built a 90 point lead here
no i need to get somebody up there
come on bludger
yes let's go all right come on other way
other way other way
[Applause]
like see there was a guy right there
and then he like flew above me or
something
right near the end
no no no no no
no no no no get over there
[Applause]
we have another team special move oh
that's them they have the team special
move
wanna bludger no the pleasure didn't
work
[Applause]
no i wasted my little defensive special
too
and then they just hit me how did they
do that
how did they time it that insanely
just just perfect timing
come on get over there
don't get out of the way for the bludger
nice job
they still use their team special so i
gotta watch out for that
like see i'm trying no no i knew it was
coming man
i knew it was coming
and they're they're gonna get 20 points
for this i think
that's so ridiculous they get scored
twice on the on the special move
there's one and right back at him
for another 20 points
man it was 100 to 90 just a few seconds
ago
and now it is 100 250 so the lead
has been trimmed
are you serious man
get over there it's ridiculous
this ridiculous usa we got to pick it up
here
what just right out from under me
okay there we go
let's get it going the other way
got a wide open person over there
yeah let's go for that right one
nice all right
they were just completely keeping us on
that their side of the pitch we couldn't
even
get the quaffle over here at all
there we go quick one dude when you can
get the quick ones like that
there we go
let's just try and keep it over here as
long as we can
get it get it yep there we go
try to get a little combo in
go for that no i was good for the far
left one
oh see see they get they're getting past
the midpoint
there we go
[Applause]
somebody wide open right there
nice okay well done well done
yeah so i heard from what you guys were
saying in the comments it sounds like
the more special and stuff like that you
do
that controls your your meter when it
comes time for the special for the
snitch
it's like you have more uh
dude if you like
they are all over it man
you do not pass recently
oh i hit the combo but they still were
able to block it
nice okay there we go what is that 130
[Applause]
140 okay nice
oh now they got a little combo going
not so fast
[Applause]
all right snitch is getting ever closer
but
they're not going to be as uh interested
in doing it because
they're getting down by a lot more now
[Applause]
yep i'm just gonna use it right now
oh and i didn't even hit with it are you
serious
[Applause]
[Applause]
there's nobody over there
passing should be easy
[Applause]
no what are you doing like why won't the
others go and get it they just watch it
it's like they don't think they can
touch it or something i don't know why
all right 160 to 50. so we're up by 110
but
still not enough to be
completely comfortable
[Music]
[Applause]
so now that i've gotten quite a bit of
this game
under my belt
this is our our third let's play session
i think
third or fourth
there we go
[Applause]
oh i should i don't know why i use that
right there because i was about to score
anyway i should have just saved it
but yeah i like the game
uh i don't know that i
love the game
it's weird like it's it's definitely a a
well-made
game don't get me wrong and of course i
mean how many years are we talking here
this is a pretty old game
but
there are just certain things that i
wish
would either be a little more clear
or it just communicated a better way to
do it
[Applause]
and i can certainly see it getting
repetitive if you uh really
you know
like i i've been kind of spreading out
my play time with it so it hasn't felt
as repetitive for me
but i could see the gameplay getting
really really repetitive
but then again i mean like people love
madden every year right they love
playing football games and nba games and
it's it's literally the same sport
every year
they're just changing up teams and
adding new modes and stuff like that i
will say like as far as like the extras
like they really went above and beyond
like the fact that they even i mean
let's be honest they could have included
just the hogwarts house teams
to make a quidditch game
and people would have still ate it up
and been really interested in it
but the fact that they like no we're
gonna include
the full
world cup roster of
players
with actual team names
the little collectibles they added
wizard cards
and then all the different stadiums
so like as far as all of that i think
they did a great job
i really do is kind of making that
an extra game in the wizarding world no
i did i get rid of it
i was trying to fire it at that left too
but yeah i think the game play could
have just used a little more refinement
almost like if they looked at like how
video games handle basketball
or even soccer like how you can kind of
pick any position and you can switch
between different positions
um and one thing that basketball games
and soccer games over the years have
really done a great job of adding
is like where you can uh target a
specific player like like i could pull
up a little menu that shows me
a button over each of their heads
so i can choose exactly who i throw to
and let's be real the other problem with
quidditch is
like it's a completely fictional sport
we don't have any real world comparison
for this i mean soccer is probably the
closest thing but it takes place on a on
a flat surface you know
this is going on in midair so the
control scheme there's a lot of stuff
they have to account for i can't believe
they got that it was all over them
oh dude the snitch is about to appear
[Applause]
and there's the snitch all right here we
go let's do this
let's do this yeah they do not have much
at all in terms of their
little speed boost
[Music]
yes yeah that's what i don't know if i
should like kind of save some of it
kind of space out how i use it
don't don't just like
use it all right at the beginning
let's see now i've got quite a bit more
[Applause]
oh no i missed it
[Applause]
what's going on
why is she not grabbing it
i'm pressing it
i'm pressing it
what is
oh my goodness dude i did not think she
was gonna grab it
i was like right in front of it kept
spamming the button and she wouldn't
grab and then she like slid off to the
side and then grabbed and still caught
it
that's so weird i don't know what just
happened there but i'll take it team usa
wins one quidditch card earned
370 to 60. so another dominating
performance for usa
and that's going to be a lot of points
let's take a look at the standings here
well there you can see the result of
some of the other games uh no one even
close to 370 bulgaria with 290 australia
with 290.
nordic team with 200
and then there's the overall standing so
bulgaria the only other team even over a
thousand
the usa though we are at 1500.
all right here we go round six i'm
actually not sure how many
of these wait i don't see team usa at
all what's going on is this like
playoffs or something
let's continue and see what happens
do we have to just wait and see okay
yeah we wait and see the results there
and let's see
so i guess we kind of had a like a bye
week or something
now australia and the nordic team over
one thousand but bulgaria moves up to
one thousand one ninety despite the
three and three records so there you go
yeah that confirms that it's more about
points than strictly the win loss
[Applause]
all right now usa is back in action
looks like this time we're taking on
australia
[Applause]
all right there we go start it off with
a steal right away
yeah see i was trying for a combo right
there i don't understand i'll take the
early lead though 10 nothing let's go
oh no they're getting away from me
i try to use a bludger and i try to use
my little speed boost none of them
worked okay there we go nice stop though
[Applause]
no i'm trying for the far left
[Applause]
there was a person over there you just
throw it even further to the left i
don't understand
[Applause]
what there's no way they would have been
able to jump in front of me that fast
i was that close that's like a slam dunk
come on
there's somebody to my right why are you
going there
[Applause]
solid start
especially on defense
let's go ahead and use that get a nice
free steel see if we can get up 50
points quick
[Applause]
okay nope right back
right back to them
there we go big time steel
okay see right when i tried to throw
that they just like vanished from me
there we go all right nice
all right come on let's get this steal
let's get a steal and then quickly just
spam the special move
there we go and it's going to give us a
nice lead
yeah and then like little things like
this
that they
kind of threw in there extra they
totally didn't have to add stuff like
this this is great i think it's weird
that you get 20 points for the team
special
i also wish it was a little more clear
on how you
earn and unlock and get to a team
special move
but i'll take it right there we're up
100
needs 60 more points
to get that ever so important 150 points
plus
lead
which completely takes out the snitch
well it doesn't take out the snitch but
it means it doesn't matter if you catch
it or not you're still going to win
although i guess the way that the
scoring is working in this game
it it does
behoove you
to catch the snitch as well because of
the fact that you know it's really about
the overall points
so you want to get lots of points and
you want to catch the snitch it's not
just about winning the match
yeah
i'm gonna try to use as many of these
combos and bludgers and stuff like that
as i can because i think that actually
helps you
get to the snitch faster
their way
oh direct hit
oh i don't think i've seen a cutscene
for the bludger before
why did you just take it right back come
on i'm trying to pass
[Applause]
i'm wondering if i take my time a little
bit more with the passing
would i actually be able to to kind of
pick a little bit better the person that
it's throwing to
[Applause]
like if i just if i just kind of stop
right here
there we go
[Applause]
hey what's up harry
all right well australia got on the
board
but we are still ever so close
to getting that 160 point lead
which again i got to keep reminding
myself it doesn't really matter like it
kind of does but it kind of doesn't
i still want to win the match
even though it's it's all about the
points really
which i think right now i'm so far ahead
in points that really is just gonna be
if i catch that snitch it's just gonna
put me even further out in front
all right that's 150.
i think they're 10 though yeah so we
need we need 20 more points
put us up by 160.
yeah get over there nice
they actually went to the hoop that i
was going for that time
oh no i missed it
all right let's try a blusher
oh another cutscene
dude have i just like
totally blanked out every time that's
happened or have i not hit one correctly
because i do not remember that
i remember me getting hit by the bludger
before
[Applause]
[Applause]
are you kidding me no
no
all right
that's the lead we need
now let's just get that snitch out
let's go
nice steal again oh team special move
for them
like who are you passing to
oh here we go
here we go here comes the team special
so that's gonna knock it under
150.
come on let me skip this let me skip
this nonsense i don't want to watch it
again watch them get their free 20
points
we're not doing anything
other than spamming a button
okay fine oh now see that just like
knocked me back on my
snitch meter
oh come on this is ridiculous
oh no no no no no
come on get up there yes nice block
[Music]
oh you're just saying you're just
throwing it up to nobody
i do not understand why you just throw
it up to nobody like that
come on
get a little speed boost there
right into that hoop nicely done
let's fire bludger their way
okay see like that one hit and it didn't
do the cut scene all right
i'm not crazy there
oh i thought that keeper was gonna get
over there to stop that one
all right 190 to 30 so we're back up 160
again
[Applause]
no like see the little star was on that
player over there on the left for a
second
and then it disappeared
like right there it did it again but
fortunately
oh we got a team special
let's do it dude
let's do it this might be enough to
get our snitch meter to be max
maxed out so we can hurry up and uh
take this victory i actually don't know
how many we have to play
so when the quidditch quidditch woke up
all right at this point we are up 200
points
pretty much just waiting for the snitch
to arrive at this point
just waiting to build up that meter
enough to where the snitch decides to
appear
another score right there again
leading this one
comfortably
oh yeah waited for that keeper to leave
that hoop
and then immediately fired back over
there
oh are you serious
all right fine let's fire blood here
and
oh i thought we missed that too but
it lasted a little bit longer than i
expected and we got it back
no
to go for the far left one
don't understand
like see right there why are they flying
backwards
they're right beside me just stick with
me and we're gonna just score easily on
this
[Applause]
i thought he'd be over there i tried to
change it at the last second
[Applause]
dude the snitch meters haven't moved in
so long
[Applause]
oh nice steal that was that one's
actually nice right there
i gotta give it to him i gotta hand it
to him on that one
oh about to score
not so fast
no
don't throw at that one
dude did that count
i hope that counted because like the
second it went through the hoop
oh dude look at their snitch meter they
got like nothing
[Applause]
oh dude i didn't know if you could
actually like grab for it way back here
or not but you can
[Applause]
oh goodness
what a surge right there at the end
all right team usa gotta catch another
snitch
and going to get just another massive
massive set of points i don't even know
if that last score counted or not
let's see how many points we ended up
here with after the snitch is added in
another quidditch card
420 points
for team usa
and we should be like far and away out
in front now
on the overall list far and away
yeah look at that one thousand nine
twenty so full a full 500 points
ahead of bulgaria it looks like they've
played one more game though as well same
for the norik team in australia and
england that looks like they've played
seven japan has only played five france
has only played five usa germany and
spain with six
all right here we go team usa versus
france and i am absolutely loving the
pitch here
just loving it no change it yes last
second it worked
[Applause]
oh dude
yeah look at the fountain down there
this is awesome
no
[Applause]
[Music]
okay see that guy in the top right
that time they didn't move
set up the perfect easy score
oh look at him going off going after
these combos early
not so
[Music]
fast i don't understand the point of the
combos i really don't
it's nice okay there we go quick 30 for
team
[Applause]
oh i was usa to try and
no i was about to try to hit a blusher
but then we got a quick easy steal
no another one
[Applause]
oh dude he got up there too it just went
by him so fast
[Applause]
all right blood your time
direct hit
use that little speed boost go for the
far left one nobody home
easy score for usa
and just like their last match
they are quickly
building a commanding lead here this
time over france
fires to the left one again the keeper
just nowhere to be found
usa coasting to an early 60
to nothing lead
again for the far left too
something about that far left too he
just doesn't want to cover that one
and just like that
we're at 70 points
i mean why not right why not far left
one again let's do it
[Applause]
and now let's just go take it right back
from them
i mean let's just build this lead as
fast as we possibly can
i don't even know what just happened
right there i think i hit the right
stick in it somehow
no
no
do you see how much traffic they threw
that one in
[Applause]
like why why did that player go behind
me
they were they were up out kind of uh
above me and a little bit ahead of me
and then as as i'm trying to pass they
just like zoom to my side
come on bludger i need you i need you
here
i don't think the bloods are connected
but
it looks like it affected them enough
all right far left one again
seems to be the best spot for us today
in this match
all right and now we have unlocked the
team special move just need to get the
quaffle back
you know what let's try this to get it
back
let's try this let's guarantee we get it
back
and so then we're going to get an easy
20 points right here with the team
special
i love how it's like inspired by
basketball
almost makes me think of like harlem
globetrotters
it's kind of just like spinning it
around
boom there's one
bounces back throws it through
for another 10 points
for team usa
that's gonna build the lead to 140 to
20.
right now with the way usa is playing
these teams are just begging for the
snitch to show up i did not mean to
throw to that one but okay
fire bludger over there yep
see now they've got their team special
which i don't know why
because they haven't done anything
they've not done anything
[Applause]
see i wish there was something i could
do
to like
i don't know if you should be able to
block
their special move but there should be a
way like there should be something that
i can do within the game
once they've unlocked it
to knock them back down to where they
can't use it or give me a way to defend
it somehow you know
it's just so weird that it's like a
guaranteed move
and that there's not really a clear way
to get it other than hey do combos
do combos score goals
and the combos aren't even really that
clear all right a nice lead though 160
to 30.
come on somebody needs to get up right
there yep come on block it nice okay
like see it's it's 2v1 right here green
now they're kind of catching up
fired over there far right
good to go
[Applause]
no why would you throw why would you
throw that one
why would you
come on steal steal steel
[Applause]
give a little speed boost
go for a steal at the last second okay
that that's like a perfect example of
where
i actually see the speed boost paying
off
like nobody home we'll take that
easy goal on the far right hoop
[Applause]
don't mind if i do
you know what let's go for the easy
steal
let's go for the easy steel right here
[Applause]
see like that time it's like almost if
you
if you push the button to shoot
before the pass arrives
then it'll do like the super fast shot
off the combo
i don't know it's it's really weird like
i feel like it's inconsistent but i'm
probably not doing something
in exactly the right way
all right what's that leave our score at
190 to 40 right now
i'm like do i have to maybe maybe i
can't do a fast pass
okay see okay maybe that's what it is
because that time it did do like the
quick shot
but it was off one of the the slow kind
of like almost like uh
um almost like a setup in volleyball you
know you kind of just like at the person
setting it up for the serve
let's see okay this one i'm gonna set up
try for that middle hoop
dude that's it that's how it works
except i
went to the right hoop even though i was
definitely trying for the middle ones
like see that time i tried it but i
wasn't close enough
and we've got another team special move
ready so here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna go for the steal using that
okay there's nobody on the ball
but we somehow got it anyway
now we're gonna immediately spam team
special
go ahead and take our 20 points for this
one
and i think the snitch is getting close
too
it would also be kind of cool if they
changed up the animations for these
as they clearly programmed a lot into
the game like every team has their own
[Applause]
but i would like to just see a little
bit
more variety with that okay so when we
scored that right there
france's side took like a noticeable
drop
score for them
but it's uh 230 to 50 right now
[Applause]
i also think it's weird that you
[Applause]
wow i don't know why he didn't move
he was just sitting on that far left one
maybe because that's the one we've been
hitting this whole time
okay that time it didn't work
maybe i didn't hold down the combo
button i thought i was though
that's a terrible shot
oh goodness
he's gonna keep stealing it though
[Applause]
there we go back to the far left one
all right 260 to 60
and we are ever so close
no i want to throw i was like please
don't make me have to wait
for the waffle or for the bludger just
because
all right here we go the snitch has
arrived
and yet again our meter is going to be
way higher
than theirs we just got to be careful
that we
kind of use it correctly here
i wonder if i if i like let it go all
the way down what happens
oh i see like it will eventually fully
recharge
and theirs will only ever fully recharge
to that that little tiny spot so their
meters just like way down at the bottom
it's only taken this many matches
i finally get it
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go dude team usa wins again
another 420 score
420 to 70 and the french stadium
unlocked very cool
all right so there you go with the
league standings we are just well out in
front right now 2
340
uh and again looks like a couple of
teams have already played eight matches
and we still have uh one more to go to
catch them
that's it for quidditch world cup but if
you are a harry potter fan then be sure
to check out my full hogwarts legacy
playlist which i will put here on this
side of the screen or if you're more in
the mood for some old school harry
potter let's plays i've got just the
thing for you as well as always thank
you all so much for watching i'll talk
to you again soon